la mort c'est pas un océan infini c'est
presque rien presque rien puisque enfin
en tout cas pour moi qui suis athée la
mort c'est rien voir moins que rien
comme disait Lucrèce c'est le néant et
donc voilà ce peu profond vaisseau
calomnieux la mort je demande simplement
avoir le droit d'en décider moi-même
dans certaines circonstances
alors me dit oui mais si tu veux te
suicider tu as pas besoin d'embêter un
médecin bien sûr mais enfin me suicider
c'est pas si facile que ça moi j'ai pas
de revolver chez moi souvenez-vous de
Gilles Deleuze le philosophe s'ouvre à
70 ans souffrant d'une insuffisance
respiratoire extrêmement grave n'en
pouvant plus voulant en finir la seule
façon que j'ai le Deleuze a trouvé pour
en finir ça a été de se jeter par la
fenêtre du cinquième étage où il
habitait lequel d'entre nous se
souhaitent à lui-même ou à ses proches
une mort pareil
enfin bon c'est vrai je peux me sauter
de la fenêtre moi j'habite au 6e étage
des centres de me rater sont limités oui
je peux et je suis en bonne santé mais
tant que je suis en bonne santé pourquoi
voulez-vous que je me suicide c'est
idiot moi j'aime la vie j'ai envie que
ça dure le plus longtemps possible mais
imaginez que ce soir j'ai eu un AVC ça
fait pour moi le quatrième entre nous
soit dit je me trouve à l'hôpital ou
dans un EHPAD et bien essayez de vous
suicider dans un EHPAD ou dans un
hôpital vous m'en direz des nouvelles
c'est impossible or c'est justement là
que je pourrais avoir envie pour de
bonnes raisons de me suicider pas quand
je suis en bonne santé mais quand je
suis malade dépendant sauf que c'est
justement quand je peux avoir de bonnes
raisons de vouloir mourir que je ne peux
plus le faire moi-même et que donc j'ai
besoin de l'aide de quelqu'un je trouve
que l'aide de mon médecin si il est
conscience j'y reviendrai et quand même
ceux qui paraît le plus naturel